Ahoj a vítej zpět v sérii kurzů Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Jmenuji se Victoria Lipinska a v tomto videu se ponoříme do toho, jak reprezentovat
daný VQE problém způsobem, kterému kvantový počítač rozumí.
Typicky se problém kvantové chemie vyjadřuje pomocí energií
systému.
Operátor, který tyto energie popisuje, označujeme jako Hamiltonián.
Nejdřív ho musíme kvantovat.
To znamená vyjádřit ho v jazyce kvantové chemie,
který se formálně nazývá druhá kvantizace.
Pokud Hamiltonián popisuje fermionové interakce, například
energii elektronů ve spinových orbitalech, mluvíme o tom
jako o fermionickém Hamiltoniánu, a ten bude naším dnešním výchozím bodem.
Qubity mají ale svůj vlastní jazyk.
Operátory ve světě qubitů jsou popsány Pauliho operátory.
Naším cílem je tedy vyjádřit fermionické operátory
pomocí qubitových operátorů.
Existuje přímá korespondence jedna ku jedné mezi
stavy nula a jedna pro fermiony a qubity.
Takže mapování mezi stavy je také přímočaré.
Mapování operátorů je ale o něco složitější.
Fermionické Hamiltoniány jsou totiž vyjádřeny pomocí kreačních a
anihilačních operátorů.
Naším úkolem je tedy usnadnit kvantovému počítači porozumění
Hamiltoniánu.
Použijeme matematické nástroje k mapování fermionického Hamiltoniánu
na qubitový Hamiltonián s gates.
Jinými slovy budeme překládat mezi
jazykem kvantové chemie a jazykem kvantového počítání.
Představ si dva řetězce, jeden s fermiony,
tedy jazyk kvantové chemie.
A jeden s qubity, tedy jazyk kvantového počítání.
Na první pohled se mapování zdá přímočaré, že?
V obou případech vidíme systémy se dvěma hladinami.
U fermionů máme buď jeden fermion ve stavu,
nebo žádný fermion.
A u qubitů máme buď stav 0, nebo stav 1.
Je to ale složitější.
Rozdíl mezi řetězcem qubitů a řetězcem fermionů
je něco velmi fundamentálního ve fyzice: to, čemu říkáme výměnná symetrie.
Dva fermiony nemohou nikdy obsadit stejný stav.
Pro řetězec qubitů je to ale úplně jinak.
Dva qubity mohou být oba ve stejném stavu,
protože qubit není fermion.
Musíme teď najít způsob, jak překládat mezi oběma řetězci.
Už v roce 1928 dva výzkumníci, Jordan a Wigner,
ukázali, že fermionické operátory pro celý řetězec
lze přesně reprezentovat pomocí qubitových operátorů.
Toto je nejpřímočařejší mapování pro kvantový počítač.
Například lze použít mapování obsazení
orbitalu na spin jednoho qubitu.
Prakticky toto mapování pro Hamiltonián vede na váženou sumu Pauliho operátorů.
To je velmi důležitý fakt, který bych chtěla, abys měl na paměti,
a vrátíme se k tomu v dalším modulu, kde si povíme,
jak se variační circuits spouštějí na kvantovém počítači.
Výše uvedené mapování znamená, že kdybychom měli například
14 fermionických operátorů, namapujeme problém na 14 qubitů.
Naštěstí existují chytré způsoby, jak snížit počet qubitů
a využít méně kvantových zdrojů pro lepší výkon kvantového počítače.
Typicky u molekulárního systému budeme znát
některé fyzikální symetrie Hamiltoniánu,
například celkový počet elektronů je pevně daný.
Tuto informaci lze využít ke zmenšení velikosti problému
bez ztráty relevantních informací.
Tuto techniku nazýváme redukcí aktivního prostoru.
To umožňuje snížit počet zdrojů, konkrétně počet qubitů,
před qubitovým mapováním jako je Jordan-Wignerova transformace.
Tento krok vypočítá efektivní Hamiltonián
a umožní nám tak použít méně qubitů.
V našem příkladu se 14 orbitaly
tato technika sníží počet qubitů na pouhých šest.
Teď můžeme v těchto redukcích zajít ještě dál.
Můžeme použít různá mapování,
která jsou o něco propracovanější než Jordan-Wigner.
Nejběžnějším příkladem je paritní mapování.
Paritní mapování nemapuje obsazení orbitalů na qubity,
ale paritu orbitalů na jednotlivé qubity.
Nebudeme tady zacházet do matematických detailů,
ale důležité je vědět, že toto mapování obsahuje další
redundance, které lze využít k odstranění dalších dvou qubitů.
Náš příklad se 14 orbitaly se tedy redukuje ze 14 qubitů
na 6 qubitů redukcí aktivního prostoru a pak na 4 qubity
dvouqubitovou redukcí v paritním mapování.
Pojďme krátce zmínit ještě jednu transformaci.
Další běžně používané mapování mezi fermionickou
a qubitovou reprezentací je Bravyi-Kitaevova transformace.
Bravyi-Kitaevova transformace používá qubity ke kódování informace
o obsazovacím čísle i o paritě kvantového stavu.
Bravyi-Kitaevova transformace kombinuje informace o obsazovacím čísle a paritě
pro bázi molekulárních orbitalů velikosti N,
kde se opět použije N qubitů.
Informace uložená v každém qubitu
se ale liší podle toho, o který qubit jde.
To znamená, že když je index qubitu sudý,
ukládá obsazovací číslo odpovídajícího
orbitalu stejně jako v Jordan-Wignerově mapování.
Když je index qubitu lichý, qubit ukládá paritu určité
sady obsazovacích čísel. Bravyi-Kitaevova transformace je nejefektivnější
když se počet qubitů blíží mocnině dvou.
Bravyi-Kitaevovo mapování kombinuje výhody Jordan-Wignerovy
a paritní transformace.
Snižuje počet qubitů, na které každý člen Hamiltoniánu působí,
což je důležité pro kvantovou simulaci, protože členy
působící na velký počet qubitů v Hamiltoniánu
vyžadují delší circuits pro jejich simulaci.
To znamená, že hloubka circuit
se Bravyi-Kitaevovou transformací snižuje a obecně
lze dosáhnout lepších výsledků na hardwaru.
To je zlepšení oproti Jordan-Wignerově transformaci,
která vede na qubitový Hamiltonián řádu N.
V tomto videu jsme tedy prozkoumali metody mapování
fermionického Hamiltoniánu na qubitový Hamiltonián.
V dalším videu uvidíme, jak co nejlépe vybrat stav
a variační formu nebo circuit.
Uvidíme se tam.